joe biden has been sworn in as the 46th
president of the united states and he's
already gotten down to work
undoing some of the policies of the
previous administration
shortly after entering the oval office
president biden
signed a stack of executive orders among
them rejoining the paris climate accord
and
reversing an immigration ban on people
from several mainly muslim countries
he's also stepped up measures to fight
the coronavirus pandemic and announced
key appointments
while his democratic party has taken
control of congress
on wednesday biden took the oath of
office promising to bring together
a divided nation
a sea change in u.s politics
[Applause]
this is america's day
this is democracy's day a day of history
and hope
of renew and resolve through a crucible
for the ages america has been tested
anew
and america has risen to the challenge
in his inaugural speech as president of
the united states
joe biden appealed to americans to
overcome their divisions
without mentioning his predecessor by
name he sounded the beginning of a new
era
in which he said truth would prevail
recent weeks and months have taught us a
painful lesson
there is truth and there are lies
lies told for power and for profit
and each of us has a duty and a
responsibility
as citizens as americans and especially
as leaders
leaders who have pledged to honor our
constitution
and protect our nation to defend the
truth
and defeat the lies
what made this day truly extraordinary
in the history of the us
was the swearing-in of kamala harris
the first black american the first
asian-american
the first woman to hold the office of
vice president
looking on was her predecessor mike
pence unlike donald trump
he had come to the ceremony to honor the
new administration
former presidents george w bush and bill
clinton were there
and so too barack obama whom biden
served as vice president
the star power was intensified with lady
gaga singing the national anthem
[Music]
jennifer lopez with a medley of this
land is your land
and america the beautiful
[Music]
and country singer garth brooks asked
everyone to join an amazing grace
but the future was heralded by 22 year
old poet amanda gorman
who took up the themes of biden's
inaugural speech in a poem
addressing the problems of the divided
nation and offering hope
for there was always light if only we're
brave enough
to see it if only we're brave enough
to be it
and joe biden 46th president of the
united states
is taking up that challenge
and joining us now from washington is
our correspondent stephan siemens
stefan joe biden's inaugural address was
all about unity but the united states
seems more divided now than ever how big
of a challenge does
joe biden face in trying to heal the
nation
no enormous enormous challenge um not
only because the
coronavirus pandemic still raging
through the united states tuesday
leaving 4 229 people dead the second
highest in a single day
in the united states not only because
that because of course there is
75 almost 75 million people who
had voted for donald trump and there is
millions out of those who still believe
who still believe now as i'm saying this
to you and who still believed on the day
of the inauguration before
president biden um
swore on his family bible
that he is not the legitimate president
that he
that the election was stolen they bought
totally
into the lies of the trump
administration
and others in the trump universe that's
how bad it is and that's how divided
this country is and that's why
um a person like this wonderful amanda
gorman this poet youth poet
made such a such an impact yesterday
for hopefully not only the people who
watched
right there on the podium what she said
but on the tv
on on their tv sets across the nation um
in in that regard it is not to be
underestimated of what the challenge of
the biden administration is
we saw joe biden right after being
inaugurated sign a whole stack of
executive orders
this is his first full day in office uh
today what's on his agenda
yeah today more of the same so to speak
but with a clear focus of
the corona pandemic coronavirus pandemic
here in the united states
and with that of course we're talking
about money he wants more money for
the states and for local authorities to
actually spend on
uh tracing the virus on vaccination
there's a breakdown it's
actually at the moment of the
distribution system so this has to be
fixed
there's states who don't have enough
vaccines anymore they're running short
of vaccinate
off of vaccines so the governor of new
york just said like he
would have to wait for it about eight
months to get in line to get his shot
because 63 years old but everybody else
before
it needs months to actually vaccinate
them so this is a mess
which biden has to clean up which the
binding administration will have to try
to clean up
but again here also the biden
administration said and
joe biden himself said there are dark
dark dark weeks to comes for the united
states there is no quick fix for this
speaking of the 17 executive orders that
was shredding
really shredding the trump
administration's
uh political uh um direction
they had the united states in that's
that was
what this was about this was historic
there was no other president who had
signed in the first day on inauguration
day 17
um executives orders directives of
memoranda
stefan thank you very much dw stefan
siemens there in washington
well germany is among the many countries
hoping to see closer cooperation with
the u.s under the new administration
chancellor angela mackel sent joe biden
and kamala harris a message
congratulating them
on their win she said warmest
congratulations on your inauguration joe
biden
and kamala harris a true celebration of
american democracy
i look forward to a new chapter of
german american friendship
and cooperation joe biden's inauguration
has been welcomed around the world
the european union and nato are hoping
his administration will help rebuild
alliances that were strained during
donald trump's time in office
dw spoke to the president of the
european commission ursula ponte lyon
i am so pleased that we once again have
a friend in the white house
i'm also very pleased that in kamala
harris we have the first woman vice
president of the united states of
america
and it is certainly the case that we
have much in common
that begins with the task of managing
the pandemic
combating climate change as well as
digitalization
but there are other issues where we have
differences of opinion
for example on the question of a digital
tax on big tech
and digital platforms there will
certainly be tensions there
but the good thing is if we are friends
if we are like-minded
then we can have welcome discussion of
these issues
and we can hold them fairly openly and
above all reliably
and then develop a common approach
together
for more i'm joined now by richard
walker dw's chief international editor
richard the eu is clearly happy to have
a more cooperative partner back in the
white house but it's not as if the
transatlantic
relationship will return to the way it
was before the trump era is it
yeah that's right terry i mean the
relief in the words from uzler fonda
lion there and also from other leaders
around europe is pretty palpable
but it is also true that the scarring
that was left by the last few years
uh is really going to be here to stay
now let's just think about what trump
really did to the western alliance he
really threw the whole question
of its logic of its viability uh into
question this was the first time
that an american president had done this
and there were real fears that if he had
been re-elected
uh that the nato alliance you know would
the united states
under him in a second term actually just
pull out of nato
leaving the europeans without a leg to
stand on in terms of
defense and that sort of fear is
something that really kind of drives
debate here in europe about
should europe really start to stand more
on its own two feet in
matters of defense but also matters of
strategic
outlook you know really important
geopolitical issues
now to some extent that is something
that the americans want but to another
it is a sign that the europeans might
start deciding to do things that the
americans don't like and that could
cause drift in the alliance
what's topping the to do list for the eu
and the u.s as as the biden
administration gets down to work richard
well i would point to a couple of things
climate we've seen that
biden has already signed the paris
climate agreement again rejoining that
and iran we could be facing a new crisis
over iran's nuclear program
uh in the weeks ahead even uh biden has
signaled that he wants to return to
diplomacy on that
you'll see close cooperation between the
two sides on that
okay so there are definitely parts you
know places where the eu and the u.s
overlap but there are also
points of contention what are some of
those
yeah well we heard from oslo honda line
talking about you know attacks on big
tech which is one issue but there are
even bigger issues than that
take for example china china has become
this superpower
really challenging the united states
more than any power
before biden wants to rally democracies
behind a kind of common line seeing it
really as a
as the beginning of a struggle between
democracy and autocracy on the other
side
but the europeans have started going
their own way on china and even just
recently agreed a new investment treaty
with the chinese side
despite the byte administration publicly
saying could you please hold off
so we can talk about this so that was an
early sign of this independence that we
just talked about
this debate in europe driving the idea
that europe needs to think its own way
on big issues
that could really cause big
transatlantic rifts
even with the kind of healing presence
that we see in joe biden
in the white house talk of strategic
autonomy not going away here in europe
richard walker our chief international
editor thank you so much
well china has also expressed cautious
hope about the change
in the white house saying it was looking
forward to working with the new
administration
however biden's team has already
condemned a decision by beijing to
impose sanctions on a number of trump
officials including former secretary of
state mike pompeo
over their criticism of china's
mistreatment of its muslim uyghur
minority
we'll have more on the view from beijing
in a moment but first let's take a look
at how
u.s ties with china nosedived under
donald trump
an expert team from the world health
organization arrives in china
a visit spot yet another clash between
beijing and washington on the corona
virus
with the u.s calling for a transparent
investigation
the team which finally arrived last week
will be
will only be successful if it is
provided
with the following information all
studies produced in china
on the presence of sars cov2 related
genetic sequence sequences and animals
animal testing results virus origin
studies
are of scientific nature we must
stop any political pressure
alongside the coronavirus tensions is an
ongoing trait and tag war between the
two countries
president trump repeatedly accused
beijing of unfair trading practices
and intellectual property theft
and what started as a tariff war also
turned political
from china's treatment of uyghur muslims
in xinjiang to the crackdown on
pro-democracy protests in hong kong
the trump administration pushed back
against what it called
beijing's aggressive behavior
today the chinese communist party is
crushing freedom in hong kong
it's threatening a free taiwan china
considers
taiwan as its internal affairs as it
sees the island nation as a breakaway
province
washington's recent moves to allow
high-level visits have hit a raw nerf in
beijing
the u.s should abide by the one china
principle and stop deeds that interfere
in china's internal
affairs and undermine china-u.s
relations
which has fallen to their lowest points
in 30 years
the current situation in china-us
relations is not what china decides to
see
and the u.s is completely responsible
for all of this
we opened our arms to chinese citizens
only to see the chinese communist party
exploit our free
and open society following a four-year
freefall in bilateral ties
it will be left to biden to decide where
to steer this salvage relationship
joining us now from beijing is
correspondent matthias berlinger
matthias
how has china reacted to the new
president taking office in the u.s
china has been very careful for now and
has has not been as enthusiastic about
the new president
as many other countries in the world
yesterday during the inauguration china
has done something very interesting
it has sanctioned a big number of high
officials in the trump administration
who were
most adversarial to china and this has
sanctioned them in a way that might harm
their future
careers it has sanctioned them their
family members
and all companies that have ties to them
which might
potentially make it a lot harder for
many of them
to find a new job if the companies are
involved in any kind of business
with china this is a clear warning to
the biden administration
that china will fight back on anything
that it sees
as an aggression towards
china uh or or confrontational politics
against
china so uh the signals they are sending
are not signals of a new start but of
a very wary position relations between
beijing and washington matthias have
deteriorated in recent years there's
trade tech taiwan hong kong the south
china sea the treatment of uyghurs the
list is very long as we saw on the
report
do you see potential for change in
sino-american relations under president
biden
well there will be change that's for
sure but i don't think it will get
back to what it was under the obama
administration
or under even more friendly
administrations like the clinton
administrations in the in the 1990s
the biden administration seems to be
under pressure to continue
a tough approach towards china and china
itself
is on its way to decoupling from the us
and to reduce its uh uh dependence on
the us so i think both countries are
also
involved in uh in in a
game of influence with other countries
with the countries of the global south
but also
with europe so i don't think we are
going to see a substantial change but
we'll of course
see a change of manners and
uh of how this battle is fought
you say they're engaged in a game of
influence well
some say that the us needs china more
than
china needs the u.s is there truth in
that matias
uh i think that's hard to answer right
now i think one thing that trump has
demonstrated
how is how dependent china is especially
on u.s technologies
he might have just just uh remember the
sanctions the tax sanctions against
huawei and zte two major chinese uh tech
companies
which always faltered under a ban to
sell
ships to them he might have reached the
opposite of what he wanted to reach he
might have
led china to strengthen its uh its own
tech industry and reduce
reliability on the us but for the moment
i
don't think we can see a clear picture
on
any country losing or or or
um yeah losing the the dependency on the
other country
both countries are both economies are
intertwined both strategic
interests meet and if there's any region
where the u.s has gained more power in
the past few years
it's the neighboring countries of china
where which are some of them are the
only ones where trump has been really
popular within the last few years
mathias thank you very much for your
analysis that was
matthias berlinger journalist in beijing